hey Rudy let's go Lina's having fun
dhoni now whoo day happy birthday to me
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning honey what's under day for
is it a play day for heading off to the
magic kingdom and we also need to sing
something happy birthday you guys happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear Lena
hey something I have a magical day and I
first thing at Walt Disney World so
magic kingdom and success
okay it is a cold day to day in Florida
what's the high of 60 60 60 which is
1660 Fahrenheit 16 Celsius no 21 14 now
it's like nine right now yeah it's cold
but it's warming up ok better than
what's happening in Toronto minus are we
ready to have a wet day what kind of all
right hey all right I liked it ok this
way let's go
[Music]
you
all right Lena's going to go take the
kids to Laden and I'm going to go get
her a copy a special birthday coffee to
warm up I'm going to get a copy here
myself too okay bye kids don't need not
go with Nyna all right cut the coffee
venti caramel macchiato femina 20 green
tea much lucky for me that was a crazy
long line up Lena went on one ride with
the kids and is on the second ride now
at the gym the lineup at starbucks is
longer Ximen line up to go there Isaac
losses as well that that's the world we
live in well Nina's going to be happy
it's her birthday she needs a warm drink
so that's how we could look who I found
how was it good you went on this ride a
lot in which i miss and then you went on
jungle cruise which i miss but we got
Nina her copy I don't know if that's
here's actually i think it is and how is
it was it worth it yeah me all right
let's keep going Nina's excited why is
it warm in here we're getting first show
I was allowed to film in there
but do we have a good time in this big
stinky stinky room that was good but
stay with snacks we're ready to watch
some bears birthday girl is all excited
Hayden is you know what she has me here
you are right we need a puppy people at
me I am potty trained okay nothing a
mother's life in heaven is potty trained
very well product no issues
[Music]
hey guys everybody huddle n I've type
two questions for you one we having fun
today okay some question I guess the
question second question is it cool
today yeah yeah very question that mean
it's too cold for ice cream today yeah
you know Johnny the lot today happy
birthday our next up Pirates of the
Caribbean
[Music]
just get me a little too big for this oh
it was the last year I massage you have
to go
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hey what do we think I'm gonna go eat
some lunch yeah
this lunchtime the boys have chicken
strips how is it
stephanie has a bacon cheeseburger yeah
me all right we got fries and apple
slices and we both have chicken cheese
burger suit time to eat up yum yum so
everybody's very cold so we're gonna
spend some time inside at the lap floor
joke having a good time just want to get
in here we got to get into this slide
a little
knocked out trying to get me my coffee
at Starbucks they're just former up one
more hands up ordering tests which is
freezing line up at the door so we'll
spend more time and not line up them in
the monsters inc line so Lina we're
going inside name is happy is it warm
all right it's warm the plane Machado
China
[Music]
for a favorite part all right Carl azuz
[Applause]
Nina here's Nina she's back are we doing
thank you how do you feel
[Music]
hey days it's been a crazy driver the
last thing we came on you're going to
drive better Wow you ready you ready
ready Wow all right ready let's go
here's the thing made it here's what I
didn't tell you i'm in charge of God
then you're in judging steering what I
never take my foot off the gas it's all
go all right this is the horse I look at
how regarding
[Music]
I don't know Queens on the wheel we're
alive barely barely
pleased with that bye
high five
and
[Music]
Lina's having fun go Nina whoo what do
you think Stephanie all right hey then
what do you think we're gonna have my
favorite ice cream it's a Twix vanilla
orange liqueur together yeah
nina email i can photobomb my shot he
does the photo bomber but we love her
and it's a birthday so it's all kids ice
cream time I get ready for the last ride
of the day what are we going to do yeah
sorry sorry let's go free sample sir
hoorah Lena has a special message for
believe nation believe that's a good
message okay so Nina's going to do a
rematch with Hayden Lena wins every year
but maybe this is the year Hayden takes
over and stephanie and Jeffrey are going
to battle each other out in their own
car with two hands of King so I'm
literally I'm not gonna film I'm not
going to film I got a competitive I need
to beat all these chumps
going to eat all these chumps so I'm not
going to film what to get in but I'm
significant
[Music]
over here even oil all right final score
220 4400 let's see another 225,000 15 to
24 how much did you get 1000 1000
homemaking up me where I oh yeah there
is the game face look at the game face
how much each of course in turn up 18
you got 80,000 you have 18,000 11 50 or
40,000 what did you get 2,000 what did
you forget I'm not saying what I got I'm
not saying what I got you don't want to
know what I got I think me no one it's
her birthday
you really want to know you really want
to know I got 224,000 yeah you know what
my machine was probably broken or
something thank you guys so much for
joining us day for disney trip hope you
had fun watching us have been fun we'll
do it again join us with a 5 thank you
so much continue to believe or whatever
your one word in love me okay oh wow a
jumping in secret only few loves the
spotlight Athena well it's her birthday
wish Tina happy birthday in the common
to she deserves a happy birthday see you
guys